hi everyone thank you for coming so yes
first things first I'm a software
engineer so I do less data science than
actual implementing the infrastructure I
have joined the data science and
analytics group two years ago and
basically we started from to three
people and we're now about 20-25 people
so it's it's growing a lot in the in the
past few years and it's it's been an
interesting ride so far what I'm going
to show you is to give you a quick
introduction of politely how many of you
know Bradley tourist yeah good but I'll
give you a really quick intro of what
Bradley has been doing and then I'm
going to show you the big project that I
worked on for the past 18 months or so
kanessa and I'll give you an overview of
the infrastructure algorithms models etc
and then what is I think the most
relevant thing at least from from my
side is how we reach to the current
solution that we have both from teams
and tools point of view and the lessons
learned along the way so P R and E is
the fifth largest tire manufacturer
worldwide don't ask me who the first
floor are because I can make an educated
guess of who they are but it's also
leader in the prestige and premium and
premium markets which basically means
all the expensive tires all the all the
expensive cars you can think of
Lamborghini Ferrari Bentley McLaren all
that cars for some of them pierre le is
the original equipment manufacturer
which makes makes it very important
basically to sign one of the brands to
kind of have in first original equipment
so that the moment they have to replace
the tire they are highly likely to
basically go for for the same brand and
this is quite an important point because
when I'm going to talk about the project
connoisseur will see that we're trying
to tackle a market where the original
equipment is not the main focus so
basically we want to convince people to
replace tires and basically adopt purely
where they didn't have clearly before
it's also the unique supplier of f1
tires so that's probably why most people
know no Pirelli as a brand it's every
time you switch the TV on and you see an
f1 race you'll see red eared wear and
has the the ground part of the calendar
which also it's quite important for the
brand what happened to Pirelli Oh over
the past two three years is a massive
paradigm shift from going from being a
mainly goods company and becoming a
services company the becoming a services
company means becoming more
customer-centric becoming more aware of
the end-user needs but also means
widening and broadening the the scope of
the products and the data related to
products with other companies that might
benefit from the use of that data so
basically means broadening the value
chain of the product they are sold to
interact with our companies that might
be interested in providing additional
services that will eventually benefit
the end user which is a very very
important point so on on this kind of
background that started about two years
ago connoisseur was the first actual
product that was going towards that
direction of putting the customer at the
center of the value proposition what is
connect so it's an Internet of Things
ecosystem that collects data from
sensors that are mounted in the tire
groups it sends this packets of data
from the sensors to a central control
unit which is mounted inside the car and
this is very relevant to the part that I
mentioned before not being original
equipment so not having the possibility
to access the data bus of the of the car
itself but having relying on on an X on
an additional tool that is mounted
within the car so that that data is then
relied via a mobile application to our
card in a cloud infrastructure and it's
then processed to generate the whole
data ecosystem that enable
providing additional services to the
end-user so depending on the data that
we have available we can make some
assumptions on providing services for
example they are Delocated or they are
dependent on the weather conditions or
depending on whether we have a puncture
or whether you have some problems with
your installations each other so it's
wiring the the spectrum of services but
it's also possibly giving information to
other companies for example with an
Imagine insurance companies that might
be interested in knowing how the drivers
are actually using their cars
the current soft software infrastructure
relies on three main mobile applications
you remember that we put a sensor we
install the sensor in the tiled roof the
the sensor itself is sending data to
dongle and then sending to the mobile
application to the cloud so the three
mobile applications are involved in this
process are pairing up that basically
makes the sensor fitting in in the tie
group the second application is
communicating so pairing the the four
sensors to the dongle unit installed in
the car and then the third application
is the end-user application kinase
itself that is used by the end-user to
monitor the current situation of the
data coming through the sensors we also
have a bunch of other products there are
byproducts of the the main cloud
infrastructure the byproducts are
actually giving additional services to
the customer service to internal
monitoring tools to basically validate
everything is up and running as expected
so giving this this broad set of tools
to loads of different personas lots of
different users that are need to access
the the data but from all from from from
different perspectives the main feature
of of kinesio is well not the the main
feature data related from from from the
data point of view that that kanessa
provides as a service is the evaluation
of the child where so the time where is
a very very important aspect of the
whole value proposition because it
affects three main characteristics of
the vehicle which are planning grit and
braking distance
all three are root causes for affected
safety so providing some data packets
that can be used to derive information
on tires is very crucial and very
important for the end user that is
actually using the system in terms of
approach to evaluating tire wear there
are two families of solutions that we
can imagine one is more related to the
physics and the vehicle dynamics so it's
kind of trying to model how the the tire
and the vehicle works so you can imagine
how the the tire spins and how how it it
gets worn with time depending on the
weather on the acceleration etc so it's
more related to the actual vehicle
dynamics and another family of problems
of actually all solutions is small
purely data-driven so we kind of
abstract from the any kind of knowledge
of how the vehicle works and we try to
model how the the the tie wears
depending on just looking from a broader
perspective at the pure data without
thinking of the physical model I'll talk
about it in a minute so one the the
approach of watching the the physical
properties it's down to watching the or
understanding the the workers in factors
so basically watching the time
attributes knowing the time attributes
knowing the the vehicle dynamics via
sort of the accelerations weight all the
driving style so everything related to
measurable physical properties of the
vehicle itself the wear causing factors
will then use be used to model an
expected wear rate which is then
integrated over the distance that the
the vehicle is actually driven to create
the result for the tie wear which is at
the end of the day number that we
estimate and we can compare with some
measurable effects of the real car that
is going out there the measurable
of the time where the first and most
important measurable effect you remember
that the the tie wear was affecting
three properties gripped breaking
distance and aquaplaning neither of
three are actually very measurable in
terms of you can it's hard to go on a
track and and and measure those values
there's one thing that is actually a
final end result of reduced or increased
eyewear which is that the rolling radius
the rolling radius is basically a
measure of how a worn tire will will we
will cover with a single spin of the
wheel in terms of distance on the road
so the the physical effect of a worn
tire at the end of the day is a reduced
radius reduce rolling radius the reduced
role in the radius will will then reduce
the amount of road that is covered by a
single spin of the wheel which is
actually the parameter that we are going
to estimate in our data model if we so
this is this is the physical model that
is actually based on physical
observations of the car of so everything
that this kind of data coming out of the
sensors angular velocity mmm
patch length which is the flat part of
the tire that is in contact with the
road so all those physical properties
are then used to evaluate the rolling
radius and gives than an evaluation of
the tire wall another approach is to
think of
the second kind of class of of
algorithms that we can use is to
abstract from the the physical
properties of the car and try to see at
the pure look at the pure data they are
for example weather conditions there are
Jewish driving style telemetry from the
sensors and think of creating a model
that that that evaluates when the tire
will need to be changed so we are not
considering anything of the physical
thing of the physical property of the
the final spin of the wheel but we are
trying to model just the intervals where
the car that the tires will be replaced
in a car so these are the basically the
two families what we have done is to
build an infrastructure that would
accommodate for all the models so that
we could have dynamically a model
selection of the the two families of
algorithm and making them run in
parallel and making them evaluate what
what is actually the best performance
given from from either from either
family so what we've done we have
created an infrastructure where we have
a service orchestration
so our basically back-end that runs on
AWS it has a data capture tool or bus
that basically receives all the data
which is which is then orchestrated via
through the services that are running in
the in the cloud infrastructure and
these these these packages are evaluated
live as we receive data we create
estimates of the tie wear with both
families of algorithms and we update the
data that we store in the cloud to make
the best prediction available depending
on the data that we have in terms of
architectural choices this has been very
interesting at least mostly for me
seeing the the the software engineering
part we started with all sorts of
different possibilities we were building
the the system from scratch so we had to
consider different aspects of the whole
ecosystem which affected not only the
the data science part so not only the
basically Python algorithms that we were
running to actually do the the
evaluation the estimate of the tower but
we had also to consider the rest of the
ecosystem that we were that we needed to
build the ecosystem means that we it's
not only back-end itself it means are
also building that the team from scratch
it was like three people at the
beginning and we had to scale up and and
have different different tools and
different people interacting with with
all sorts of things we had to hire
people physically to join the team
so we also needed to to choose the right
technology that could be also scalable
in terms of the possibility to hire
people that would actually know that
technology so that's why we opted for
a Java back and forth for the main
restful infrastructure so that the the
mobile apps are actually interacting
with with the restful back-end running
Java spring but the the the data science
bit itself is running on on a Python
container that will will run the the
models in in parallel depending on what
we actually need to to run it's all
running on on AWS and we tried to be as
cloud independent as possible as we knew
that we had then in the latest maturity
of the codebase itself we had to migrate
to possibly two different technique
Louds which is something that is that is
happening now so in terms of there's
there's a lot of at least in in the web
architecture there's a lot of buzz
around serverless architectures at the
moment I don't know if you any of you
have used a server less and in any sort
of form like lambda on AWS yeah so you
might know that there's a there's a big
limitation in lambda
both lambda on honourably ice both on
the size of the package that you create
and the execution time so there's a
strict limit of 30 seconds in the
execution time and I can't remember the
size but it's kind of 50 megabytes of of
code that you can package in a single in
a single lambda function so and
shifting towards other possible
solutions would be quite complicated
because you write code that runs on a
specific infrastructure and you want to
actually abstract so that the moment you
need to make it run somewhere else it
will it will run smoothly in terms of
dev team this is not super interesting
in terms of that dev team we went
through a very important learning
process of putting together people they
were coming from very different
backgrounds so we had vehicle dynamics
were typically more mathematical
physical background so they tend to work
with the MATLAB spreadsheets or hardware
so there they're kind of the lower level
in terms of software and in language is
used lower level meaning also closer to
the physical representation of the data
itself we kind of had a level of
abstraction above the data science team
that we're looking at data from more the
modeling and algorithmic part so working
mainly with Python
our Scala and all the technologies we're
talking about in these days here we had
to run the algorithms on an
infrastructure so we had the digital
product development team interacting
with the IT department but merely so it
you can see probably as another step
above
so putting together the things that the
the the other teams were creating and
making them work in the infrastructure
and the of course the the cyber business
unit which takes care of the actual
implementation of their hardware which
is kind of a separated business unit a
completely different world from the rest
of the the software engineering part and
and that probably has proved to be that
the trickiest work for integrating the
various tools in in a single ecosystem
we put the algorithms and the models at
the center of the whole thing and doing
so you can kind of see how the flow of
of the development and the learning
process were was going data science team
having starting at the beginning with
some training data that was provided by
vehicle dynamics vehicle dynamics
creating the testing data set from
indoor testing so basically everything
was was prepared in lab at the very
beginning just even to see if it was
feasible as a process or as a final
result so indoor testing days are going
through physical physical validation and
then feeling the this physical
validation into the models that were
used by the data scientists feeding back
to the cyber unit that were tweeting the
algorithms running on the firmware and
on the sensors to tweak parameters for
all the evaluation of the angular
velocity so the this data was
particularly at the beginning feeding
back directly into the team doing the
hardware to actually physically change
things in in the in the parts that they
were producing and then everything else
everything composed putting together and
and creating the infrastructure that was
developed by the the digital product
development team in terms of integrating
the these very different teams we had to
make choices of a lot of lots of
different things from version control to
using Python iPad notebooks from
test-driven development using a shared
platform sharing test across the teams
it was it was a very interesting
challenge to see how the different teams
were needed actually to learn from each
other how to interact how to change how
to exchange data how to even package
data so that one team could use the data
produced by another team etc and for the
some of them not even knowing of version
control for example so some of the team
from vehicle dynamics never had to open
a github repo before so it was a it was
a very thorough and an interesting
learning process lets us learned
cross-functional team
[Music]
works if we make the the clearest and
most transparent assumptions on what the
tools are never give anything for
granted
sit down together make things very clear
on how to for example put a package of
data somewhere on nice three rather than
use it a github repo it's never we all
the people involved in the process are
very smart and very knowledgeable of
their specific field but not necessarily
know how to interact with with the
others the separation between soft and
hardware has been painful I don't think
we have a solution there the the in
terms of practices unless everything is
done under one roof it's very hard to
make the iterations quickly and and
check that the process the actually the
progress of the hardware development
that's because probably in hardware
development they come or at least the
people we work with they come from a
more kind of waterful approach while we
kind of adapted quite quickly to an
agile process so combining the two is
it's always been improved quite hard so
the ideal setting would be to have one
product one team under one roof and
working together in reality this is very
hard to achieve while for the
architectural choices
always try to find a blend of
cutting-edge research with very
down-to-earth pragmatism and having
something that works quickly that can
iterate fast that can also be modular
risible so it can be replaced with
something new
consider vendor lock-in I mention I
mentioned lambda functions before server
lists is nice is something that
everybody tries these days but you might
end up in using something that is not
usable somewhere else we recently
started the migration to the Chinese
market and Chinese market means that we
cannot use AWS because there is no
Amazon in in China so we need to use
Alibaba and Alibaba has kind of one to
one match for most of the technologies
but there are a few things are
completely different for example we used
cognitive for user authentication and
there's no equivalent on the other Baba
cloud for a cognate or authentication so
we need to restart writing the
authentication part from scratch and try
to make it modular as well so that it
can be replacing in the codebase yeah
and with and with data start as soon as
possible with with testing data whatever
whatever is it was feasible and try to
either it as as quickly as possible
particularly if hardware is involved we
I don't know if you ever happen to build
any kind of hardware it might be it
might be beneficial to start with a very
simple proof of concept that could run
on 25 pounds raspberry pi for example
and then probably isolate on that model
and and actually finalize it as a as a
custom FPGA or whatever hardware would
be at the very end and this is pretty
much thank you very much for a very
interesting talk we have now five
minutes so seven actually for some
questions so I will go around with a
microphone hello
please keep Spain a bit more about what
you're measuring on how your field test
differed from your love tests and also
how you're able to get ground truth out
in the fields in the world so thank you
yeah so the the the main values that are
used to there's data depending on okay
so the the main values that are coming
out of the center of pressure
temperature angular velocity and patch
angle patch angle is the you can imagine
a tire mounted on the car the first
approximation of a tire shape is a
circle but it's actually not a circle
because the the weight of the tie will
make the the bottom parts in contact
with the road almost flat the patch
angle is basically how wide is that flat
part in the circle and the patch angle
changes depending on the how the the
tires were so the the data coming from
out of the sensor are basically these
four parameters
and on the basis of those values you can
have the approach of modeling the the
the physical representation of the tire
in that case angular velocity and patch
angle are kind of most important while
if you try to abstract and have a more
kind of abstraction data-driven
of the whole algorithm you would be
interested in seeing also the variation
of pressure temperature etcetera because
they will also affect the driving style
etc also we because we are sending data
to a central control unit the central
control unit has a accelerometer that
can gives they can give information
about how the vehicle is manned and
there is actually a GPS there but the
GPS data as you can imagine it is quite
sensitive so we are using it for indoor
testing mainly to much information on
the way they're using weather API but
never use that for final end clients any
more questions
hi go back to the actual physical
modeling you mentioned MATLAB why didn't
you use or did you use any CFD and you
just fed the data into the code the CFD
data CFD data no in terms of so the data
that we were using at the very beginning
was from a subset of tires that we
wanted to address mainly for the
specific market that we are going to
tackle for those kind of tires we
initially adopted a quite simple
exponential kind of function that would
have good results in terms of modeling
that the time where exponential izing
the real depth of the of the tire so
that was a good enough solution for the
the beginning of the implementation of
the models and progressively adding
information is still an ongoing process
I don't know if I reply to you I think
we have time for one more question
okay so after conducting your lab tests
to calibrate your sensors how can you be
sure in the real world on real roads
your let's say you measure the punch
angle is accurate
like can you ground truth it in the real
world only how or how do you how do you
do it it's so you can if you limit to
the models of tires that you use so that
that's kind of a business choice of
addressing one market more than the
other so I mentioned that they use the
pedal is leader in the prestige market
that means that in terms of specific car
it's basically two three cars that are
relevant in terms of market and they're
basically the course
nine-one-one and those kind of cars so
you can ground truth if you if you limit
to a subset of all the variable data and
that's actually when you start widening
to to a broader range is when you start
receiving some serious noise from from
all other possible brands and everything
there's no really good solution at the
moment if not having the cars out there
and
having data coming from different motors
okay let's thank Tom again thank you
[Applause]